Oh,
well that's a long story.
So,
um,
I was in retailing,
I went to city college and I went to fit
and I was in retailing for awhile and I
was working for a company called gimbals
in New York City and they were going to
close shop.
They sold the real estate here right
here on 33rd and Broadway and I was out
of a job.
So I said,
Oh,
you know,
I've always been,
well I've been working since I'm 16
years old.
I said I was married at the time and I
was able to take some time off.
So I took some time off and some friends
of mindset to me,
let's open a cabaret.
And I said,
oh,
that might be fun.
So we opened this cabaret on Eighth
Avenue and 26th street and they named a
caroline's.
Well,
once my name was on the door,
then I had a little more than invested
interest in it.
So I said,
Oh,
this might be fun,
you know,
helping run this club.
So we started with lots of cabaret acts
and when that quite,
it really didn't hit me.
I mean,
it wasn't contemporary enough for me at
that time.
Then we started to book comedians like
Jay Leno and Jerry Seinfeld and Garry
shandling and billy crystal and peewee
Herman.
And that was the start of,
of Caroline's as a comedy club.
Oh,
watching the David Letterman show that
was on it,
you know,
12,
30 at night.
Uh,
Jay Leno was kind of a regular on that
show.
So I kind of Said,
Oh,
let me tie it into one if we can get him
on the show when he said Caroline's and
he can mention that he's there and then
people come out to see him.
It was a way of,
of saving with advertising,
but getting the word out,
I guess it was called marketing at that
time,
so kind of we did it that way and I kind
of built our reputation.
He was a working comedian.
He worked around the country.
He had a small following at that time,
but they came out to him and it was kind
of my contemporaries at the time.
Jay and I are,
you know,
like the same age and his clientele was
the same age as that time and,
and they came out to Sam,
followed by people that were on the rise
like Jerry Seinfeld and Garry shandling,
Sandra Bernhard,
Rita rudner.
I mean,
it's everybody that's kind of made it,
came through the club
I think.
Um,
I think I was talking to an agent at
that time at Apa and Jerry was there and
he said,
well,
you know,
agents are always trying to sell you a
so talent.
Anyway,
so he suggested that we,
we booked Jerry and we did A.
Jerry worked at the club for a number of
years and I remember him doing a few new
year's eves there.
So it was Kinda fun years ago.
I think a lot of people came through our
system,
you know,
we,
there were a lot of people where we had
them as we,
we put them as opening acts.
I mean,
Chris,
Chris Rock was a young kid when he
started to work at the club.
Um,
and when he last appeared at a club,
we had a,
a young comedian called Wanda Sykes and
Wanda,
we put wander as an opening act and
introduced to the Chris and after that,
you know,
she kind of,
her career was made and she worked.
She worked a lot with Chris with Chris
Rock.
Maybe I take it for granted.
The people have come through there.
I mean lots of producers.
Larry David and Michael Patrick King,
Jon Stewart,
Jon Stewart who was a writer on a TV
show that I had for a and a for six
years.
So it was also him and Michael Patrick
King.
I mean,
when I look back at some of the fun
things that we did,
you know,
when the early nineties,
you can see where these guys were headed
to,
after that.
Um,
we,
we start a lot of people at.
There's a young woman,
Lisa Lampanelli,
we,
we let her come in and let her perform
there and build her following.
And she went on to do not to be very
funny lady.
So things like that.
Um,
I think how I watch Comedians,
I've watched them grow Sunday night.
I was watching the Oscars and I watched
John Stewart and I was thinking last
night I wanted to send them a note,
you know,
I remember him as a 27 year old kid
standing with me at a bar at the club
that I had at the seaport,
you know,
talking about his mother to me and um,
just to go back into,
to see how he's grown over the years.
It's just quite amazing.
That's almost 20 years ago when I,
when I met John,
you know,
I did a Kiddie show with John at the sea
port on a Saturday morning.
I wish I had the tapes of that right
now.
He's grown,
he's grown.
He's,
you know,
he's,
he has his own voice.
He grew into himself.
Um,
he's,
he's just a real,
real big,
big
hello.